ja manchmal findet man prächtiges
exemplar da draußen in bayern wo die
windräder ganz einsam hinter kirchen
stehen sehr ein windrad ich sehe einen
mann sie müssen der wind könne also wenn
der winter hat grüß gott
wie viele windräder haben sie persönlich
als wind komme schon zu verantworten wie
stehen und sich drehen noch gar keins
der hörer an schlechter wind können auch
an der wind kamera ist er erst seit
einem jahr im einsatz und der
zeithorizont einer einer
windkraftprojekt planung müssen sie
rechnen wahrscheinlich fünf bis sechs
jahre was schon immer ihr kindheitstraum
wind kamera zu werden
nein
dies ist die geschichte vom wind kamera
der gegen die windkraft gegner kämpft
aber auch gegen gefährliche waldbewohner
die den windkraftausbau im wege stehen
welcher waldbewohnern nervt dann am
meisten wenn man so ein windrad bauen
will der uhu die haselmaus oder der
bayer die haselmaus ist tatsächlich ein
problem weil auch wenn man sie nicht
findet man musste ein jahr warten und
victor ihre mutter reservoirs an und
wenn sie es nicht geholt hat dann kannst
du die wurzelstöcke entnehmen also wenn
man windrad bauen will muss man ein jahr
lang das futter reservoir der haselmaus
beobacht wichtig werden sie eigentlich
noch ernst genommen von freunden und
familie als wind kubus man ja auch immer
mögliche seltene tiere im blick haben
die das windrad gefährden können absolut
absolute der rotmilan
wespenbussard der eu nicht zu vergessen
auch die zauneidechse
und da hinten dort muss fassen hofen
lieben also ab ins auto denn der
bürgermeister setzt sich für windräder
ein treffer rückte und was sind so die
größten hürden die sie überspringen
müssen ja grundsätzlich braucht man erst
einmal die politische bereitschaft ist
verfahren überhaupt anzugehen und ist
eine frage der eier und deswegen glaube
ich gibt es ein wenig windräder in
bayern also das ist eine frage der würde
das ist eine frage der eier denn
durchschnittlich bürgermeister zieht
sich ungern den unwillen teile der
bevölkerung auf sich was schlägt man
sich lieber auf einzelne seiten und
versucht es allen recht zu machen aber
es gibt bei der windkraft werde mir das
heißt eingebautes windrad drei genehmigt
sie müssen ja monströse kröten haben
und sie werden immer größer gut dann
herzlichen dank herr bürgermeister sehr
aufschlussreich wir müssen weiter wir
müssen uns kümmern um den wind viele
rücken danke doch ein mann in der
bayerischen regierung möchte für mehr
windräder jede hürde nehmen sie nennen
ihn hooksiel
wenn man es ganz kurz und knapp sagen
würde warum brauchen wir mehr windräder
um mehr heimische energieerzeugung zu
haben um weniger abhängig zu sein von
energieimporten und warum sind die
bayern zu dumm um das zu begreifen die
sind nicht so dumm sondern die wege
neben ob er vielleicht ein kompromiss
dass wir sagen doch atomkraft aber alle
endlager sind in bayern ja diese debatte
wird der zunehmende eröffnet dass er
versucht wird bayern ein
atommüllendlager aufs auge zu drücken
muss ich natürlich strikt ablehne weil
ich sorgt bei uns passen die
bodenformation nicht für den indoor
soccer mal angeguckt haben sie schon
ganz gut eigentlich so wie andere detail
ausgewiesen werden nervt aktuell denn
mehr markus söder oder der
ministerpräsident es darf ich hier nicht
öffentlich sorgen kann man auch hier
unter vier augen herr aiwanger sagte mir
dann erst nach dem gespräch dass markus
söder im tierisch auf die nerven geht
[Gelächter]
sie sagen ja immer der wind in bayern
ist zu unbeständig aber selbst der wind
in bayern wechselt nicht so auf die
richtung die sie falsch bayern ist immer
ein starker wind
bläst immer nach vorne immer noch von
immer nach vorne dann schaffen sie doch
10h ab und stellen immer ein paar
windräder auf
die räder stellen benziner aber dann
bleibt ja kaum platz für windräder
wir haben sonne wir haben wasser sie
haben auch wind viel weniger
der windatlas von ihrem ministerium sagt
was andere doch doch
doch doch machen wir jetzt hier louis
definiert oder was
doch so alles gut werden kommen wir da
nicht zusammen wird klar wie heute nicht
heute kompromissangebot sie schaffen 10h
bei wind ab und die heute show hält bis
zur sommerpause 10h abstand von ihnen
das muss ich mal weg das wird ein
ernstes an
wir haben gesagt die sollen meinen
lieblings witz erzählt es mache ich
gerne also kommen ein pferd chef base
und der papst in einer bar sagt der
barkeeper
ronny endlich den zwei takten heute
schon kanal also geht doch